[Music]
when i was at my kid's birthday party
and they asked so what are you doing
right now i'm a presidential candidate
it turns out that 83
of the districts in america are either
very blue or very red so if i get
through to the general election i win 42
of both democrats and republicans now
regard the other side as evil the united
states political stress level is
literally at civil war levels so for
those of you who think that this is
realistic it's real i mean we saw it on
january 6th it turns out that 62 percent
of us want an alternative to the duopoly
but we keep being told we can't have one
we keep being told that oh you're going
to mess it up you're going to mess it up
for someone else all we need to do is
move to rank choice voting and then the
spoiler effect is solved